[Music]  in Canada I heard you people were quiet  and polite in Canada the government is  moving forward with a plan to legalize  assisted suicide yeah that's right now  if the right to die law is passed the  Canadian tourist Bureau is ready with  some brand-new slogans for Canada here  to read them as my pal Andy Richter  Canada go north before you go South  Canada where the morphine drip Slyke  make maple syrup Canada  time to die Canada come see what the  afterlife's  all aboot Canada the only place north of  us is heaven Canada would it kill you to  visit Canada is it cold or is it just  you Canada  hey want the last thing that you see to  be a moose or something well all right  let's get her done and finally Canada  what the hell else is there to do  [Applause]  last word through me what are you  muttering about over there adlet last  words through me just imagine I did that  one right folks  so laziest thing I've ever heard you  said what pretend that didn't happen  you